[Music]
thank you back at the line because I'm
fighting Han not someone over here not
some world with it Tim and I don't wanna
XY two-dimensional fight and Fighting's
you to start rotating
weights on the back leg is doing the
same reconciliation so you cook you all
and this egg comes up and then yet
reconciliation so you to find this space
inside you going around this place so I
find the space inside back to Center
so round yet wounds here open your thumb
is lower
one minute next finger boom thumb and
index
[Music]
okay so this tater the tower is getting
a lot of energy that I can say that I'll
do it up here
see I did it you don't always have to
come to this you will always end up
though with the angle cancellation on
his body and I'm back diagonally on his
line of attack I will never end up like
this and he will never end up straight
up and down or stopped this way
little weird inside just not okay
what's wrong is this that's wrong
this is stronger immediately no hand is
grabbing it whoa no hand is grabbing it
I just here here just touch it I'll
already have the adhesion right then he
moves his hand right here to follow
bring your other hand in like a sword
like this put open cut in dirt keeping
in this back corner in the back corner
don't turn the arms behind you keep the
arm in front of you
arm is in front of your forehead burner
forehead whoo
top you boy headed turn to forehead
forehead surgeon right here man your
forehead
forehead step to the new hand is on my
forehead and then I'm going to just turn
and shift my weight on to them new head
has the outside head comes up boom and I
don't double dip it you see don't double
dip it it's too hairy always single
digits single give it shift enter
single pivot you see all this boom
singing pivot shift step spin it
or head turn when I go like this
he's got more mechanical advantage pull
it down you see you can't hold it up so
I'm never pulling you down here right so
I constantly say to you this BOP corner
in this back corner one step I stay in
it that's why you don't pull it end up
there you're not in it you step into it
and keep into a bowl then you turn all
the way
don't grab the farm hold here here at
the wrist bones you see just hold you
can't really get a grip yet so don't
grip yet hold step whoa
and I end up here here not on the
forearm keep your arm straight right and
strong meatball stand up you want this
wrist and turn in on him boom so I have
an alleged
Wow
right there it is it's gonna be there
whoa boom
you think sear I am okay
extend torque boom Oh Carrie not on the
form here okay let's try this is the
mistake you get the farm so wrong here
here and you want his elbow in and okay
so you don't want to double down do you
guys see that so this is starting the
term and continues it so that you okay
boom
step to it and you have to get rid of
this straight line you want this to
torque clean Cheers
so it's under you under your weight you
see he tries to live he has to lift my
whole body but when I'm like this and he
could pull this long you see okay so
boom pop boom he's under you okay
yeah and now we insured this is first
beginner variation just enter and they
had going down
you think the Hat is on the floor take
the other hand and push this down and
there's your pin you see that then the
strike hopefully she blocks Jay Chou's
pin the weights on that and strike down
[Music]
him strike so this would be incorrect
get out of it you need is forearm flat
on the ground here underneath then the
strike boom so not like that
you're gonna get okay alright
okay so right there you're pulling it
from the back to the front and from the
right to the left okay and that means he
can pull it cut to the back you'll go
[Music]
and that's a pull to the back from the
back to the front
and that's a jenna pull from the box of
okay and when i everything is fine here
but when i go like that that's where he
is stronger than me
so what am i doing is i'm here his hand
stays off my forehead
watch the other one for head turns hands
on the back of my head on my hand stays
on the front of the head don't turn her
head and then bring it back to their
this okay same thing if I don't stay
there now I'm going to bring it around
I'm bringing it for my right to my left
you see and you can pull it back the
same way
leave it here oh there's no pulling no
pulling over and no holding ladder okay
try to get nice
here don't go here do this or when I get
here
keep the foot that is going keep it
going with turning you see that's what
makes the elbow go up then and now
continue turning turning
boom you're here hey Jeep Dakota - going
all the way to disappears at going you
won't over that - now we keep turning
put your dash
[Music]
for a beginner level okay on the X
property we have the tilts right and now
right now we're just pulling him you see
but where it is the second long bill on
the X it goes that way so this one just
pushing down and this one is going